في اخر التطورات الميدانيه في حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها دمرت احد مراكز صنع القرار
للقوات الاوكرانيه واسقطت مروحيه اوكرانيه
من طراز ام اي 24 قربك راماتورسكا في
مقاطعه كما تحدثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
صدر قواتها لهجمات اوكرانيه على دونيتسك
وثلاثه هجمات اخرى على زبالوجيا من جهه
اخرى اعلن حاكم مقاطاعات بالجورد وبريانس
كوارسك تعرض المقاطعات الثلاث لقصف
اوكراني
نذهب الى تنضم الينا مباشره من هناك
مراسله هناك
القصف وهل جرى تحديد هذا المركز لصنع
القرار كما وصفته روسيا والذي تم تدميره
في اوكرانيا
نعم سلمى ما يمكن قوله فيما خص هذا الموقع
الذي تم قصفه تحدثت عنه ريدوفكا موقع
ريدوفكا العسكري الذي قال انه على مقربه
من كييف وكان فيه عسكريون مرتبطون بالقرار
الميداني والقرارات المرتبطه بهذه العمليه
العسكريه وقد جرى استهدافه وزاره الدفاع
تحدثت عن اصابه الهدف بنجاح وفق قولها
ولكن ما زالت المعطيات المرتبطه بهذا
الموقع لم تعرف بشكل كبير ولكن هذا
الاستهداف مرتبط بطبيعه الحال بمجريات
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وهذه الجبهات
المتحركه في الايام الماضيه وخاصه بعد
الاعلان عن الهجوم المضاد سابدا من حيث
اتواجد من مدينه دانياسكا التي شهدت في
الساعه الماضيه تكثيفا للقصف الاوكراني
طالع عددا من الاحياء والمناطق فيها عدد
كبير من القذائف والصواريخ طال هذه
المناطق وايضا لغايه الان ننتظر لنعرف
المخلفات وربما الاضرار التي لحقت
بجراءه هذا القصف هذا القصف مرده سلمى الى
استعاري جبهات القتال فدانيتك وحدها فيها
ثلاث جبهات شمالا
القتال فيها مستعر محاولات الجيش الروسي
مستمره لخرق دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه في
تلك الجبهه جنوبا مارينكا وهذه المنطقه
التي تحدثت عنها قبل قليل وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
اذا ما جمعنا عدد الهجمات في دنيتك التي
صادتها القوات الروسيه وفق اعلان وزاره
الدفاع نتحدث عن عشر هجمات اوكرانيه وفيزا
بروجي الحديث يجري عن ثلاث هجمات اذا
تكثيف هذه الهجمات ما رده الى ان ووفقا
قراءه الخبراء العسكريين مرده الى ان اي
تحرك في خطوط القتال لم يجري في الايام
الماضيه القوات الروسيه تريد ان تحقق
تقدما باتجاه المناطق الواقعه تحت اطارات
القوات الاوكرانيه ولكن ايضا بدورها اقوات
الاوكرانيه تقوم بعدد من الهجمات القراءه
الروسيه لما يجري في الميدان انما كانت
تريده اوكرانيا في بدء هذا الهجوم هو مد
خط من تلك المنطقه من هذا التقاطع بين
مقاطعه
وصولا الى بحر ازوف عند ماريوبل وبريديانس
ولكن هذا المخطط احبط بفعل التحركات
الروسيه وباتا الامر يقتصر على هذه
المنطقه التي يجري فيها كارون وفار
واعلانات للسيطره على امتار من هنا او من
هناك سلمى اخيرا الانظار شاخصه الى مقاطعه
خرسون تحدثت المواقع العسكريه يوم امس عن
قصف روسي طال عددا من الزوارق للقوات
الاوكرانيه التي حاولت عبور نهر دينيبرو
شكرا لك كارمن جو خضر مراسلتنا من دوني